[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mardi 29 novembre voici le programme
tous coupables ils m'ont marier de force
c'est le livre publié par nous aux
éditions ballon un ouvrage bouleversant
où l'auteur met en avant son mariage de
force avec son cousin à l'âge de 18 ans
elle évoque aussi la violence et
l'insensibilité de sa famille envers
elle Julien Leroy a recueilli son
témoignage le mardi c'est le jour de
votre page culture dans le 7 8 au
programme de ce soir les 40 ans d'art
gravure la programmation et la
rénovation du Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et une
exposition totem de l'amitié à la
médiathèque de la verrière le mardi nous
partons également à la rencontre des
chefs cuisiniers yvelinois il vous livre
leur recette avec son propre astuces
pour que vous puissiez ensuite les
reproduire chez vous cette semaine c'est
Eric Voiron des terrasses de
Clairefontaine qui vous cuisine sont
neuf pochés et nous partirons aussi à la
découverte d'une distillerie en Vallée
de Chevreuse qui produit du whisky du
rhum ou encore du gin mais tout de suite
avec moi en plateau Gabriel Gonthier
journaliste de la rédaction bonsoir
bonsoir Mathilde vous allez nous
présenter les informations d'aujourd'hui
oui Mathilde dans l'actualité
aujourd'hui on a la remise des prix 2022
du label ville et village fleuri alors
12 villes ont été récompensées dans les
Yvelines on parlera également de la
visite de la ministre délégué en charge
de l'égalité homme-femme à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et notre chiffre
du jour lui sera consacré au prix du
passe Navigo et donc ce sera dans
quelques instants avec nous également
Lionel masetta bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur du Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la scène
nationale a ouvert ses portes en
1993 cela va bientôt faire 30 ans et
prévoyez des travaux des grands travaux
de rénovation alors qu'est-ce que ça va
concerner de quoi à quoi on peut
s'attendre ça va être juste on va les
travaux devraient commencer pour les 30
ans c'est à dire en septembre
2023 ça va être un travail de de
rénovation intérieure des deux salles et
puis une extension du théâtre sur le
parvis pour y construire des espaces de
convivialité restaurant brasserie lieu
d'attente billetterie etc etc
on en parlera plus en détail dans
quelques instants avec nous également
Chantal Roumy bonsoir bonsoir et
Catherine delmel bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous êtes toutes les deux membres de
l'association Art gravure Sky cette
année vous fêtez vos 40 ans alors ça
représente quoi pour vous les 40 ans de
art gravure un grand événement parce que
nous fêtons nous faisons chaque année
des portes ouvertes au moment de
décembre mais cette année on va leur
donner une coloration toute particulière
on les veut très festives on veut
s'amuser parce que on a 40 bougies à
souffler sur notre gâteau d'anniversaire
les l'atelier existe depuis 1982 donc
voilà on est tous heureux d'inviter tout
le monde à venir souffler ses bougies et
on en parlera dans quelques instants
également mais tout de suite je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'oeil à la
météo de demain
matin dans les Yvelines le ciel devrait
être très nuageux sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
il fera à 6 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
5 degrés à Versailles Rambouillet et aux
dents dans l'après-midi le ciel devrait
rester couvert compter 7 degrés à Houdan
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles il fera
environ 6 degrés à Rambouillet et demain
ce sera la Saint André Le Point
maintenant sur l'information de jour
dans les Yvelines
et c'est avec vous Gabriel Gonthier on
commence par l'image du jour cet
après-midi avait lieu la remise des prix
2022 du label ville et village fleuri
créé en 1959 il garantie une démarche
d'amélioration de la qualité de vie une
gestion durable des espaces paysagers et
public et le respect de l'environnement
alors de nombreuses villes yvelinoises
ont été récompensées bon un ville en
gatois et Saint-Germain-en-Laye ont reçu
la troisième fleur des prix spéciaux ont
également été accordés à Saint-Cyr
l'école qui remporte le coup de cœur du
jury cette année et l'animation de la
démarche revient à Élancourt alors dans
les Yvelines 68 communes sont
labellisées et 12 villes et villages ont
été récompensés plutôt dans la journée
l'Institut woman safe and chill Dren de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye a reçu une visite
ministérielle oui ce matin Isabelle
l'envirome donc la ministre délégué
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes s’est rendu à l'Institut
woman safe and children la bien sûr
accueille les femmes victimes de
violences et leur offre un
accompagnement cette visite s'inscrit
dans le cadre de la politique de lutte
contre les violences intrafamilales à
noter que la ministre était accompagnée
de son homologue belge s'arrachide un
mot de sport maintenant avec le match de
l'équipe de France qui va se dérouler
demain oui alors l'équipe de France
c'est déjà qualifié vous le savez c'est
donc l'occasion pour le sélectionneur
Didier Deschamps de faire tourner son
effectif le pissiaquer Matéo gaine Douzi
milieu de terrain de l'Olympique de
Marseille de 23 ans devrait être
titulaire pour ce match et demain dans
l'émission nous recevrons à Guy Galanti
président du club de foot de morpa qui
vient de débriefer sur ce match et votre
chiffre du jour ne va pas satisfaire
ceux qui utilisent le Pass Navigo
Gabriel ce chiffre c'est 90 ça ne vous a
pas échappé j'imagine d'autant plus si
vous prenez les transports en commun le
7 décembre le conseil d'administration
doit voter le nouveau tarif du Pass du
Pass Navigo 90 euros soit une hausse de
20% mathil en cause la perte de recette
liée à la crise sanitaire ainsi que la
hausse des prix de l'électricité Valérie
Pécresse président de la Région
Île-de-France et Île-de-France mobilité
cible dans les colonnes du Parisien hier
la responsabilité de l'État son
indifférence également face au voyageur
France simulant francilien actuellement
le prix du passe Navigo mensuel s'élève
à 75 euros par mois dimanche dernier
avait lieu le Salon du livre oui on
revient sur la cinquième édition du
Salon du livre qui s'est déroulée ce
week-end à la Commanderie des Templiers
d'Élancourt auteur éditeur libraire se
sont réunis sur le thème quand le cinéma
et le livre se rencontrent parmi les
personnes présentes cette année
l'actrice Évelyne dress présidente
d'honneur du Salon le journaliste Nelson
manfort ou encore l'acteur et écrivain
Thierry Carbonnière après une coupure
liée à la crise sanitaire les
organisateurs et les auteurs étaient
heureux de se retrouver malgré une
fréquentation en légère baisse cette
année et vous avez une info de dernière
minute oui une dernière information
tragique un drame ces produits ce matin
au Port-Marly un motard est décédé ce
mardi sous les routes d'un camion de 28
tonnes sur la départementale 113 une
route considérée comme très accidentée
par le maire de la commune Cédric pempa
Marie merci beaucoup Gabriel Gauthier
pour ces informations un mot sur la
grève des chauffeurs de bus à 50 ans en
Yvelines vous pouvez retrouver les
lignes qui circuleront demain avec les
horaires prévus sur le site internet www
trafic.skibus.fr les horaires seront mis
à jour dans la soirée et si vous aussi
vous voyez une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous le communiquer en utilisant le
hashtag 7 8 news
[Musique]
et on passe tout de suite à notre page
culture on en parlait en début
d'émissions il y a quelques instants le
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
s'est lancé dans de grands projets de
rénovations mais avant de parler de ces
travaux Lionel MACETA quelle est la
programmation de cette année et de
l'année
2022-2023 quelles sont les têtes
d'affiche il y en a beaucoup en fait
quelle est la programmation il y a plein
de spectacles et 180 représentations
donc ça fait beaucoup les têtes
d'affichage à venir il y en a pas mal il
y a Vichy Cohen qui ne va pas tarder il
y a le rappeur Youssoupha également
cette fin de semaine il y a un
Blanche-Neige très particulier il y a un
sacre du printemps très particulier
aussi il y a un chorégraphe hip-hop
brésilien Bruno beltrao qui arrive au
mois de décembre également donc la
programmation est particulièrement
fournie avec au programme de la danse de
la musique et du théâtre du théâtre de
50 ans en Yvelines c'est à dire que
c'est une scène pluridisciplinaire on
essaie de programmer tous les styles
toutes les esthétiques du spectacle
vivant alors on va parler un peu de la
fréquentation des salles de spectacle
car selon
[Musique]
une étude
qui pourtant des Français ne vont plus
au théâtre et 28 % ils vont moins
souvent alors est-ce que c'est le cas
sur la scène nationale depuis le début
de la saison on est à 80 aux alentours
de 90% de toute fréquentation c'est à
dire qu'on a un taux de fréquentation
qui est supérieur à la saison
2018-2019 c'est à dire la saison juste
avant le covid donc c'est un rebond qui
est très impressionnant je veux pas dire
qu'ils nous surprend parce qu'on a tout
fait pour y compris pendant cette
période de crise sanitaire on a été
vraiment toutes les équipes ont été très
présentes sur le terrain on a changé
modifier nos moyens de communication nos
outils de communication
et l'année dernière était une année de
reprise où on était aux alentours de 70%
de taux de fréquentation et la dès cette
année alors avec des habitudes qui
changent un tout petit peu dans les
réservations beaucoup plus de
réservations de dernière minute mais au
final la quasi-totalité des salles sont
quasiment pleines donc on est très
heureux de voilà d'avoir fait et
poursuivi ces efforts pendant ces deux
années et demi qui était fort
compliquées
de la crise sanitaire est-ce que
l'inflation aussi qu'on connaît
actuellement ne n'empêche pas les gens
de venir au théâtre pour l'instant ça se
ressent pas mais ça va se ressentir un
moment ou un autre et puis l'inflation
va pas se ressentir uniquement dans le
fait de sortir de ne pas sortir au
théâtre ça va se ressentir dans nous les
contrats nous signons les prestations
que nous avons dans certainement les
subventions que nous percevons donc ça
touche quelque chose de beaucoup plus
large qu'uniquement la sortie des
spectateurs mais pour l'instant et grâce
subventions que l'on perçoit du
département de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin bien entendu de la région
et de l'état on peut maintenir des prix
des prix des tarifs bas ce qui permet à
beaucoup de gens de sortir et puis on a
aussi des tarifs qui sont très
spécifiques en fonction des ressources
des personnes des situations des
personnes qui viennent nous voir
c'est notre mission et alors en
septembre vous allez lancer des des
grands travaux on en parlait un tout
petit peu en début d'émission qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que ça va concernés est-ce
que vous pouvez nous le redire plus en
détail oui en fait c'est pas nous qui
allons lancer c'est l'agglomération
puisque c'est l'agglomération de 50 ans
en Yvelines qui est propriétaire du
bâtiment l'agglomération et les
partenaires financiers de ce de ce
projet lorsque le théâtre a été
construit en 1987 septembre il a ouvert
en septembre 1993 il était finalement
assez différent des plans qu'avaient
conçu l'architecte initiale Stanislas
Fisher puisqu'il devait y avoir sur le
ce qui est l'actuel parvis il devait y
avoir un espace par restaurant il devait
y avoir également une réserve des
ateliers de décor à l'arrière du
bâtiment ça n'a pas été fait pour des
raisons de coûts et de maîtrise des
coûts que l'on peut comprendre et
aujourd'hui c'est ces éléments manquent
et avec l'agglomération
l'agglomération qui est sur une notion
une réflexion plus qu'une réflexion sur
la qualification de ce qu'on appelle
l'hyper centre de 51 en Yvelines la
question qui s'est posée c'était quelle
est la place d'un théâtre qui est au
bout de l'avenue du centre c'est à dire
qui est visible à 2 km de l'endroit où
il se trouve qui est dans un lieu hyper
passant et comment est-ce qu'on peut
travailler sur le théâtre pour en faire
un élément de lien non pas un bâtiment
intimidant c'est pas c'est pas un
jugement sur l'architecture de ce
bâtiment moi que j'aime beaucoup c'est
un bâtiment imposant mais c'est un
bâtiment voilà imposant ou intimidant
comment est-ce qu'on peut faire en lien
entre ce bâtiment et cette place qui va
être requalifiée où il y aura un peu
plus de place pour les pour les piétons
et en fait le projet qui a été choisi
par par l'agglomération de 50 ans et ses
partenaires c'est un projet qui est un
trait d'union qui fait du parvient
véritable trait d'union entre le
bâtiment et la place parvis qui va être
couvert de façon extrêmement élégante et
qui va pouvoir accueillir un restaurant
assis une brasserie où on pourra
grignoter un peu plus rapidement un
espace de détente et bien entendu la
billetterie qui sera aussi un espace de
déambulation qui redonnera l'intérieur
du théâtre c'est ses qualités qui fera
du théâtre une véritable balade
architecturale donc un restaurant qui
sera ouvert et une brasserie ouvert midi
et soir l'idée c'est que le théâtre vive
au quotidien
plus convivial
de lui donner des attributs des qualités
qui n'a pas entièrement aujourd'hui qui
est en charge de ces travaux
l'agglomération et les partenaires ont
choisi une jeune agence qui s'appelle
l'agence Fagard Fontana et les ningets
qui étaient sur les 68 agences qui ont
postuler qui faisait vraiment partie des
outsiders et qui est certainement celle
et c'est certes pour ça qu'elle a été
qu'elle a été retenue qui qui tenait
compte à la fois de l'existant et des
marqueurs du bâtiment du grand bâtiment
actuel c'est à dire l'arche la verrière
la façade de façon Auguste Perret qui
avait des préoccupations écologiques et
qui avait des préoccupations de
comment dire de de possibilité de
transformer d'utiliser de manière
différente ce grand espace ce qui est
créé que que les archives ont baptisé un
grand lobby urbain donc cet espace peut
être utilisé de plein de façons
différentes donc toutes les qualités
étaient là pour que ce projet soit
retenu y compris des questions de coûts
et de facilité de mise en œuvre de ces
travaux justement le coup vous le savez
rapidement oui aux alentours de 8
millions d'euros avec une un soutien des
partenaires à hauteur de 5 millions
d'euros dans 3 millions d'euros qui
restent à la charge de l'agglomération
de 50 ans en Yvelines et bien merci
Lionel masetta
avec nous je le rappelle vous êtes le
directeur du Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on part à la
découverte d'une exposition maintenant à
la médiathèque aimée Césaire de la
verrière totem c'est l'oeuvre de des
habitants des 12 communes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le reportage
réalisé par Grégory canalet et Régine
ralech lancé 2D attribution d'une boîte
sélection de matériaux et place à la
création ce sont les règles que c'était
fixées Agathe bezo pour réaliser
l'exposition ludique le processus de
création se faisait autour du jeu et
tous les Yvelines étaient invités à
participer
[Musique]
en fait quand les médiathèques ont
sollicité sur ce projet donc dont la
donc le brief c'était de faire une
action collective qui relie les publics
j'ai proposé cette notion de totem parce
que ça m'intéressait d'être dans la
construction de l'amitié et il y a pas
besoin entre guillemets d'être habité
ici ou ailleurs on a on est relié par
un lien un peu indéfectible qui est
invisible mais qui est là entre humains
en fait et je trouve que c'est ce
qu'elle les met en valeur et en lumière
c'est en juillet dernier kayad bezot a
démarré son processus de création à
partir d'ateliers de rue l'exposition a
pris forme dans plusieurs villes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines notre action
culturelle au sein de l'agglomération
c'est entre autres de créer du lien
entre les habitants de créer du lien
entre les villes et de faire corps pour
créer cette identité de territoire à
laquelle nous sommes attachés des copies
de l'oeuvre finale seront exposées dans
chaque médiathèque de l'agglomération et
ce de manière définitive
l'association Art gravure faite ses 40
ans cette année ce sera le week-end du 3
et du 4 décembre prochain pour en parler
Catherine delmel présidente de
l'association Art gravure et Chantal
Roumy secrétaire de l'association alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez prévu pour fêter
ces 40 ans alors pour pour ces 40 ans on
a bien sûr notre gâteau avec les
carottes bougies dont je parlais tout à
l'heure mais nous avons une exposition
sur nos murs de gravures qui sont de
format 40 sur 40 le chiffre 40 va
revenir de manière constante cette
exposition elle va présenter des
gravures de toutes sortes de techniques
et les graveurs seront là présent pour
répondre aux questions des visiteurs
pour leur expliquer il y aura aussi des
démonstrations ce qui pourra encore
mieux faire comprendre la technique de
la gravure il y a aussi des livres
d'artistes des objets en tout genre des
dis ça que des tops
des cartes des créations comme des pin's
des boîtes vous pourrez aussi également
une tombola oui voilà il y aura cet
animation de tombola ça c'est pour faire
animer il y aura 40 gravures alors c'est
40 gravures à gagner elles seront
toujours de 40 sur 40 mais dans les deux
jours il y en a il y en aura 20 un jour
et 20 un autre jour et puis il y aura un
buffet qui sera constamment présent pour
accueillir nos autres voilà il y a
dimanche un petit intermède musical
violon et percussions enfin bref on
espère une ambiance familiale tout
autour de ce de cette technique qu'elle
a gravure Gabriel 40 ans d'anniversaire
c'est un succès avec toutes ces années
qu'est-ce qui fait le succès de Dark
gravure finalement alors
qui s'occupe donc de quatre cours
dans la semaine un le soir comme ça
c'est assez c'est relativement nouveau
pour permettre à aux gens qui
travaillent pour pouvoir venir le soir
c'est une manière justement de faire
perpétuer le savoir autour de la gravure
certainement et puis nous avons aussi un
beau patrimoine avec nos machines nos
nos on a quatre presses pour la taille
douce on a une presse pour le bois
disons que on a aussi une presse mais
bon que l'on utilise moins pour la
typographie on a aussi tous les
caractères bref c'est une je veux dire
c'est un atelier qui a vraiment tout
pour travailler la gravure alors que ce
soit les techniques plus anciennes que
ce soit les techniques plus modernes on
sent que vous êtes passionné par la
gravure pourquoi cette passion
en fait on a découvert quand on la
pratique on découvre des beaucoup
beaucoup de techniques différentes et
finalement et qu'on arrive aussi à
combiner et puis évidemment c'est aussi
le fait que ce soit convivial qu'on se
retrouve ensemble à créer et ça c'est
toujours extrêmement agréable et puis on
apprend toujours parce que il y a de
nombreuses techniques entre les voilà
les techniques anciennes et puis jusque
aux techniques contemporaines voilà qui
qui se développe même encore aujourd'hui
donc c'est vraiment passionnant en fait
vous avez des matériaux très différents
vous passez du cuivre vous passez aux
zinc et puis tout d'un coup vous pouvez
prendre du plexiglas vous pouvez prendre
du carton vous pouvez prendre du bois
tout ça sert comme support à la gravure
donc vous avez vraiment une palette très
très riche de techniques je dirais
presque que c'est
jubilatoire d'avoir tout ça devant soi
et de pouvoir créer alors agravure faite
c'est 40 ans est-ce que il y a quelque
chose qui vous rend fier
particulièrement en tant que présidente
en tant que secrétaire de cette
association oui moi ce qui nous rend
fier c'est que on a quand même eu pas
mal d'obstacles à surmonter avec le
covid la récemment parce qu'on a dû
fermer c'était pas évident on peut
remercier nos adhérents aussi parce
qu'ils ont contribué quand même à nous
aider à survivre on va dire combien
d'adhérents environ
et oui alors on est fier parce que on se
donne beaucoup de mal pour se faire
connaître pour rayonner dans toute la
l'agglomération donc depuis ces 40 ans
avec toutes les expositions que nous
faisons pour chaque année on a des
projets chaque année donc c'est quand
même beaucoup de travail parce que je
rappelle que nous sommes tous bénévoles
par notre professeur qu'elle salarié
mais donc voilà on fait des une
exposition pratiquement chaque année
dans dans toutes les villes de
l'agglomération à Montigny à plaisir à
Guyancourt enfin etc et aussi à
l'extérieur on a même fait des échanges
avec les États-Unis et l'Italie et aussi
inter association en ayant fait venir
aussi des des relieurs parce que
reliures et livres d'artistes voilà ça
ça pouvait marcher ensemble donc voilà
beaucoup d'échanges et beaucoup de on
est fier aussi parce que comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure on a un patrimoine
entre les mains qui sait effectivement
donné depuis 1982 bon alors avec la
succession des professeurs successions
des présidentes mais ce matériel qui est
une grande j'allais dire d'une grande
qualité on a des presses qui datent
un patrimoine qui est on en est fier
voilà on est on a envie de en prendre
vraiment soin merci Catherine delmel et
Chantal remis d'être venu en plateau
pour en parler avec nous si vous êtes
intéressés rendez-vous les trois et
quatre décembre prochain à la zone
d'activités des 4 œuvres et si vous êtes
amateur de VF quand vous regardez un
film vous avez sûrement déjà entendu sa
voix Donald Reignoux et dans le métier
depuis 30 ans parmi sa vaxographie
Titeuf Andre Garfield ou encore Jess et
zenberg et chose que vous ne savez
peut-être pas Donald Reignoux a grandi à
Bois-d'Arcy il est l'invité de Mélanie
poquet dans un nouveau numéro du
vyby on regarde un extrait
je suis tombé dans le petit par une un
petit coup de pouce mais j'ai entretenu
cette chance et mais j'en faisais pas
une un objectif et le doublage avait pas
la la
visibilité qui a maintenant
mais c'est vrai que c'est cool ça
parcourt atypique et puis par le chant
et pourtant vous chantez pas souvent je
crois que ça parle la Reine des Neiges 2
c'est vrai que c'est pas mon fort le
chant ça me permet d'avoir des rôles
souvent chez Disney parler chanter mais
je suis pas proprement parler chanteur
parce que je suis pas je m'entends pas
les capacités donc en comédien je suis
capable de proposer dix versions
différentes par prise et qui ont rien à
voir en chant je suis capable de chanter
juste ça s'arrêtera là donc je peux pas
interpréter plus que ça on est arrivé
presque à aujourd'hui mais au début vous
dites des chants des voix des semelles
et le premier rôle vous tapez quand même
très fort Andy Toy Story
ce n'est pas le premier rôle mais en
tout cas c'est le premier vrai rôle qui
m'a lancé effectivement
c'est vrai que le bouche-à-oreille après
ce film là a été énorme et voilà vu
qu'on est dans les Yvelines j'étais au
collège Mozart et j'ai arrêté le collège
traditionnel le jour de l'avant-première
pour partir en cours par correspondance
et il m'avait dit que que c'était pas un
métier de faire comédien donc
je peux comprendre parce que c'est un
métier qui fait peur c'est un métier qui
est qui est précaire moi je m'en sors
très bien et qui est très hasardeux mais
c'est vrai que on peut très vite avoir
des des longs moments sans travailler
donc je peux je peux comprendre qu'ils
étaient inquiet mais je suis content
d'avoir eu raison de croire en moi c'est
la fin de notre page culture retour sur
l'actualité dans le département
on en parlait en tout début d'émission
tous coupables ils m'ont marié de force
et le livre publié par nous aux éditions
Balan un ouvrage bouleversant ou
l'auteur met en avant son mariage de
force avec son cousin à l'âge de 18 ans
Julien Leroy a recueilli le témoignage
de Nour je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait alors vous avez grandi dans une
fratrie de cet enfant d'une famille
originaire du nord du Maroc
vous parlez d'une famille très
traditionnaliste avec des coutumes du
site farfelu et puis à l'âge de 18 ans
vous apprenez par votre cousine que
votre cousin marocain voulait demander
votre main
on vous explique que c'était comme ça
dans la famille on se marie contre nous
et lors des vacances au Maroc juste
avant votre retour en France
votre père vous a imposé un mariage avec
cet homme comment est-ce que vous avez
vécu cette ce moment
j'ai été trahi
je pense que je ne réalisais pas
l'ampleur
des choses à ce moment-là
ou vraiment là où ça m'a vraiment ouvert
les yeux c'est qu'on va emmener chez le
médecin
me faire un certificat
et puis voilà j'essaie de demander de
l'aide
j'ai écouté une demi-sœur qui me disait
de le faire semblant de y arriver en
France
même si les papiers je ne savais même
pas ce que je signais je ne savais même
pas que c'était pour faire le enclencher
la procédure
il précise quand vous parlez de
certificat vous parlez de certificat de
virginité c'est ça donc le médecin vous
dit que voilà votre père est votre
tuteur c'est lui qui voulait imposer
donc vous pouvez rien faire
de force on le fera si même si vous
refusez
et alors ce moment qui est terrible une
fois que que vous retournez en France
votre famille a du partir au Maroc pour
s'occuper votre de votre grand-mère qui
était souffrant
et là vous décrivez la violence terrible
et cruelle de votre cousin qui était
venu en France
vous étiez seul avec lui dans
l'appartement familial
cet homme vous a violé insulter il a
même filmé l'axe en disant que vous lui
appartenir
et malgré les appels à l'aide auprès de
votre famille personne ne vous croyez et
cet homme est accueilli comme un roi
comment comment vous expliquer le fait
que que votre parole n'avait pas
d'importance vis-à-vis de cet homme
plus une femme on ne croit pas la femme
c'est l'homme qui
chez les rois qui décide qui
va pas pouvoir sur la femme comment ça
se passe au quotidien je sais pas par
exemple dans votre travail je sais pas
si on peut en parler c'est très
difficile c'est difficile j'ai dû
changer de travail
il y avait beaucoup d'hommes ou je me
sentais pas bien
je me sentais mal étouffé
et j'avais l'impression de revoir
de quoi que ce soit encore aujourd'hui
vous trouvez vous avez des doutes
là-dessus
je me dis j'ai forcément fait quelque
chose
pour en arriver là pour
et pourtant j'ai toujours été droite
j'ai toujours
et il y a aussi ce moment où à l'hôpital
vous allez pour des problèmes de santé
et le médecin vous apprend que vous êtes
enceinte de votre cousin
vous aviez le sentiment de porter
l'enfant du diable
et vous parlez dans le livre de la de la
culpabilité de cet avortement vous avez
dû faire parce que vous pouvez me dire
davantage par rapport à ça
j'ai fait quelque chose de grave
je pense que je n'avais pas le choix
c'est
si mon cousin le récit va
[Musique]
soit une nourriture soit je serai encore
avec lui de force
ici la prend que j'ai amorti de son
enfant et
et il est capable de tout
l'enfant du diable
et à la fin du livre vous dites
qu'écrire ça a été votre thérapie vous
n'aviez plus que votre plume comme ami
vous écrivez dans le livre
qu'est-ce que ça a présenté d'écrire ce
livre pour vous
beaucoup de choses
honnêtement je pensais pas être encore
encore là au jour d'aujourd'hui
quand j'ai écrit
mon histoire c'est je pensais vraiment à
me
mettre ma vie
j'ai envoyé tout ça ma meilleure amie
pour le signe trace
et justement vous en parler aujourd'hui
vous avez un mari vous avez un enfant
avec ce mari aussi
c'est eux qui vous donne la force
d'avancer aussi
quel est le message que vous voudriez
faire passer aux femmes qui qui vivent
parce que vous avez vécu
adorent parler et ne pas se taire
ne pas avoir honte
ne pas se sentir coupable surtout
surtout pas
merci beaucoup merci pour pour ce
témoignage que vous avez livré
aujourd'hui merci et pour pour ce livre
que vous avez écrit
merci infiniment à vous
et le témoignage sera à retrouver en
intégralité prochainement sur notre site
Internet et sur notre antenne le Medef
au nom des employeurs et la CFDT au nom
des salariés organise jeudi prochain à
la mairie de Versailles une matinée
consacrée à l'emploi des personnes en
situation de handicap et pour en parler
avec nous Florence Mercadet choqué
bonsoir bonsoir alors pourquoi cette
réunion vous a paru nécessaire alors
elle nous a paru nécessaire parce que
les choses évoluent quand même
relativement doucement
et on a toujours une problématique de
discrimination à l'embauche il faut
savoir que sur les chiffres à peu près
70% de discrimination sont liées à un
handicap de la personne qui vient se
présenter donc
il y a des mesures il y a des moyens il
y a des obligations
des contraintes des sanctions et les
entreprises ne sont pas forcément
toujours informés de l'étendue et de la
portée de cette loi donc
c'est une information avec plein
d'acteurs du secteur de des personnes en
situation de handicap qui viennent pour
informer expliquer et il y aura des
témoignages également qui seront qui
seront développés oui justement la loi
oblige les entreprises à employer 6% des
personnes en situation de handicap
est-ce qu'elle est bien respectée vous
venez de le dire que les entreprises
n'ont pas forcément au courant alors un
elles sont pas forcément cons alors
cette loi concerne toutes les
entreprises sur l'obligation d'avoir des
personnes en situation de handicap mais
les sanctions et l'obligation des 6% ne
concerne que les entreprises de plus de
20 salariés
alors il y a plusieurs types de sociétés
il y a des sociétés qui nous disent NON
je veux pas embaucher de personnes
handicapées parce que c'est
déstabilisant parce que si parce que ça
il y a des sociétés qui aimeraient
recruter des personnes en situation de
handicap mais qui n'en trouvent pas
enfin il y a pas de
n'arrive pas à recruter de personnes
dans ces situations là qui sont à 4,5%
mais qui arrivent pas à atteindre les
6%, alors il y a d'autres solutions pour
atteindre les 6% qui avec une embauche
en direct mais on est à 4,6% de taux
d'emploi nationalement donc on n'y est
pas aussi pour ça encore même s'il y a
des progrès des améliorations dans les
faits les sanctions elles sont vraiment
appliquées elles sont vraiment mises en
place elles sont appliquées elles sont
appliquées et elles peuvent être lourdes
puisque la sanction maximum c'est quand
une société pendant trois ans
volontairement n'embauche pas de
personnes en situation de handicap il ne
fait rien la condamnation c'est 1500
fois le taux horaire du smic par le
nombre de personnes handicapées qui
doivent réduit être embauchée et vous
dites que dans certaines entreprises ils
n'arrivent pas à trouver des personnes
handicapées est-ce qu'il y a pas aussi
un peu de mauvaises volonté de leur part
finalement je pense pas parce que le
taux de chômage
c'est 8,4% des demandeurs d'emploi qui
sont des personnes en situation de
handicap mais 60 personnes 60% des
personnes en situation de de handicap
arrive quand même à avoir peu ou Prous
un peu de un peu de travail donc les
choses avancent des choses avancent et
les sociétés qui n'arrivent pas à
recruter qui sont à 5 % déjà si elles
sont à 5 %, c'est déjà beaucoup en
fonction du nombre de salariés bien
évidemment mais 5% c'est déjà beaucoup
et elles sont de bonnes volonté quand
elles disent nous on aimerait atteindre
le taux de 6% c'est leur intérêt
le problème qui se pose aussi c'est
qu'il y a des personnes qui sont en
situation de handicap mais qui ne le
disent pas
parce que elles ont peur justement de
discrimination de se faire exclure
d'être stigmatisé dans l'entreprise
parce que 80% des personnes en situation
de handicap sont des handicaps qui ne
sont pas visibles
et donc elle n'ose pas le dire alors ça
ça se décoince un peu là on arrive quand
même à évoluer sur ce point là avec des
personnes qui osent dire qu'elles sont
en situation de handicap et quels sont
les préjugés les plus répandus au sein
des entreprises que
qu'elles arriveront pas à s'adapter
qu'on aura du mal à les faire travailler
que ça coûte cher que il va falloir
faire de l'adaptation
ergonomie et tout ce qu'on veut sauf que
voilà les sociétés savent pas qu'il y a
des aides des Agefi pour débloquer des
aides que les dépenses sont déductibles
enfin voilà il y a des tas de choses qui
peuvent venir je pense que le
l'argument de l'économique n'est pas un
bon argument après c'est sur l'insertion
nous envoyer ça fait des faire des
efforts alors que très franchement
faire de la de la diversité et quelque
chose de riche et c'est ça qu'il
faudrait que les entreprises comprennent
et c'est là-dessus sur tous les aspects
positifs et sur ce côté là qu'on va
insister
jeudi matin le 1er décembre lors de
cette lors de cette conférence qui va
durer à peu près trois heures ce qui
nous permet d'avoir le temps d'entendre
surtout des témoignages
pendant cette matinée là et bien merci
Florence Mercadet choqué que cette
matinée est ouverte au public et qu'elle
a lieu ce jeudi 1er décembre à la mairie
de Versailles un peu de sport à présent
on va prendre la direction du Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines il
a accueilli la troisième étape de Lucie
traque Champion's League il y avait du
spectacle dans les tribunes avec plus de
3000 spectateurs le reportage de Michael
elmidoro et Grégory canalet
[Musique]
des lumières de la musique une piste qui
s'illumine bienvenue sur la troisième
étape de l'UCI track Champions League un
événement programmé pour la première
fois au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et qui réunit
les meilleures pystars mondiaux avec un
objectif en tête pour les organisateurs
casser les codes l'ADN de lucetrach
Champions League c'est vraiment de
fabriquer de l'entertainment autour du
cyclisme sur pitch donc des animations à
travers de la nouvelle technologie on va
conserver exclusivement les formats les
plus impressionnants en matière de sport
toujours autour du cyclisme sur piste et
c'est vraiment voilà pour se démarquer
de ce qui peut se faire d'habitude et de
continuer à développer cette pratique
d'attirer encore plus de monde des
familles comme ce qui se fait en
Angleterre à Berlin d'attirer tout ce
monde-là en France et plus
particulièrement à 50 ans en Yvelines au
total plus de 3000 spectateurs sont
venus voir ce spectacle ce samedi 26
novembre le show il est très bien ils
ont mis de la musique il y a de
l'ambiance avec les jeux de lumière ça
change de comme d'habitude c'est mieux
comme ça mais je crois qu'ils ont trouvé
le bon principe pour faire vibrer les
spectateurs et faire venir les tous les
tous les passionnés de vélo dans les
Vélodrome le public a pu voir une
victoire de la favorite locale Mathilde
de gros la piste qui s'entraîne dans la
structure c'est imposé face à la
Colombienne Martin Bayona en vitesse
elle termine deuxième sur le Kirin
[Musique]
c'est toujours des superbes émotions en
plus il y avait beaucoup de monde donc
vraiment c'est cool ma famille toujours
au même endroit dans les tribunes non
franchement c'est ça fait que des bons
souvenirs pour toute ma vie quoi Lucie
trek Champions League devrait revenir
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition au plus grand bonheur des
spectateurs
[Musique]
noël approche à grands pas et vous avez
peut-être déjà votre calendrier de
l'avent si ce n'est pas le cas Mathilde
Rimbert propose des calendriers de
l'avent et de l'après sur une centaine
de thèmes différents mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'un calendrier de l'après
réponse dans le reportage de Céline
Charles comment tenir son verre de vin
composé son menu de Noël ou encore
apprendre les bonnes manières à table le
tout en 25 cases c'est ce que propose
Mathilde Rimbert avec ses calendriers de
l'avent fait maison donc les 25 bisous
avant Noël spécialement pour enfants
entre deux et dix ans à peu près donc à
l'intérieur on va avoir chaque chaque
jour une petite un petit une idée de
bisou donc là on a le bisou magique les
parents vont s'amuser à bisous sur le
nez bisous éléphant à la base le
calendrier de l'avent c'était vraiment
une une affiche avec des petits dessins
à l'intérieur on n'avait pas toutes ces
calendriers à chocolat à objets etc donc
j'ai vraiment voulu reprendre cette
cette idée des calendriers de l'avent
mais aussi de l'après sur des thèmes
différents traditions du vin posture de
yoga mariage ou encore naissance plus de
100 modèles de calendrier sont
disponibles depuis chez elle Mathilde
Chapron de A à Z leur fabrication l'idée
c'est de faire travailler des
illustrateurs toujours dans un style un
petit peu un petit peu en fond de teint
ou dans l'esprit de Noël qui eux
m'envoient une illustration de base et
moi ensuite sur illustrateur je viens
appliquer donc le gabarit on retrouve
chaque petite case qui elle après voit
découpée à la machine
tout est coupé et rainuré donc ensuite
on passe au collage la plus grande
partie des calendriers se vend entre
octobre et décembre Mathilde en assemble
un peu plus de 200 par jour en cette
période des calendriers à glisser entre
le bouquet de fleurs et les chocolats
qui seront vous faire attendre Noël avec
plaisir ils sont à retrouver sur le site
calendrier événement.fr
vous avez déjà votre calendrier de
l'avent Gabriel oui moi je suis restée
sur un calendrier plutôt traditionnel le
classique calendrier au chocolat mais
j'ai découvert des choses et vous non
moi j'ai pas encore mon calendrier de
l'avent faudrait que je m'y mette parce
que c'est jeudi le premier des 30 je
vous propose maintenant de partir à la
découverte d'une des trois rares
distillerie artisanales d'Île-de-France
la Fabrique à l'alcool elle est située à
péqueuse à la limite des Yvelines et de
l'Essonne elle distille du whisky du
rhum ou encore du jean et produit près
de 20 000 bouteilles par an le reportage
de Céline Charles bonjour Christophe
Astori je suis un des deux fondateurs de
la distillerie la Fabrica alcool
Cédric j'ai fondé avec Eric keno mon
associé en 2017
on fabrique essentiellement ici donc des
spiritueux du whisky du jean de la vodka
des romans
donc la matière première du whisky en
fait c'est du malt d'orge que l'on
reçoit ici c'est du malt qui vient de la
région du Berry le malt on va le
transformer dans une sorte de farine on
va concasser les grains et cette farine
va monter dans la salle de brassage donc
cette toute cette partie là
à l'intérieur en fait il va y avoir un
mélange entre la farine et l'eau qui va
être brassé donc vraiment dans le sens
propre du terme c'est vraiment mélanger
comme pour fabriquer une bière et le
liquide en fait qui en sorte qui en
résulte va être pompée dans le dans des
cuves qu'on appelle des fermenteurs et
dans lequel on mettra de la levure et le
liquide va rester
fermenté en fermentation pendant trois à
quatre jours c'est en train de créer de
l'alcool en fait tout simplement et donc
ce liquide qu'on appelle du mood bière
donc qui est comme une bière
traditionnelle dans lequel il y a pas de
houblon c'est ce qui fait vraiment la
matière première du whisky
on cherche cet alambic avec 1300 litres
de moules bières qu'on va distiller
donc c'est à dire mettre en chauffe
monter en température et une fois que
les la température de 78,6 degrés est
atteint en fait les premières vapeurs
d'alcool comment ça à sortir vous avez
la chauffe dans la cuve en cuivre
les vapeurs vont monter dans le chapeau
au-dessus
et là on a deux possibilités de
distillation on fait soit une
distillation qu'on appelle à l'écossaise
soit une distillation à repas
[Musique]
et les deux barriques en fait de style
de barrique sont vraiment la signature
de la distillerie c'est à dire que la
valeur ajoutée leur rapport aromatique
est très différent les barils de Bourbon
qui ont contenu du bourbon vont amener
beaucoup de rondeurs beaucoup d'arômes
sucrés comme un peu la caramel vanille
peut-être une pointe de banane et la
barrique de Bordeaux au contraire va
ramener des notes beaucoup plus sèches
beaucoup plus tanniques beaucoup plus
boisé
beaucoup d'incrédulides d'incrédulité au
départ de dire mais comment on peut
faire un whisky en Île-de-France à
Chevreuse voilà c'est pas possible le
whisky s'est fait revenir dans l'Écosse
donc beaucoup de surprises
mais avec vraiment beaucoup d'intérêt et
le fait qu'on soit dans une démarche
d'ancrage local
va aussi dans le sens en fait des gens
de la région
[Musique]
et deux types d'activités sont proposés
à la Fabrique alcool des visites de la
distillerie sur rendez-vous pour
apprendre à fabriquer des spiritueux et
une activité d'atelier bien dans ton
jean vous avez compris le jeu de mots
Gabriel où les gens viennent distiller
leur propre Jean ils élaborent la
recette avec des professionnels et
peuvent repartir avec leur propre Jean
je le rappelle tout de même l'alcool est
à consommer avec modération comme chaque
mardi on retrouve les astuces de nos
chefs Yvelines noires pour réussir vos
plats aujourd'hui c'est le maître
restaurateur des terrasses de
Clairefontaine
Eric Voiron qui a ouvert les portes de
sa cuisine à vous Gabriel Gontier on
regarde tout de suite votre reportage
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Eric Boiron je suis
chef de cuisine aux terrasses de
Clairefontaine aujourd'hui je vais vous
présenter une recette d'automne avec des
œufs pochés au cèpes et aux girolles
avec un coulis d'agastache
pour commencer on va prendre une petite
casserole on va y mettre de l'eau
minérale
[Musique]
on va y mettre à ébullition dès que ça
commence à bouillir on va y mettre notre
œuf bien frais
9 et gaucher
correctement on va le mettre dans de
l'eau glacée pour arrêter la cuisson
[Musique]
je vais vous faire voir comment on fait
le pistou et on comprend un blender on
efface toute la gastache
[Musique]
on prend de la bonne huile d'olive on
mouille quasiment à niveau un niveau ça
veut dire au niveau des feuilles
une fois mixées
[Applaudissements]
pour piquer l'oeuf exactement comme le
pistou on met la gastache dans le
blender ensuite on met de l'eau minérale
comme ceci et comme le pistou
on mixe
voilà ce qu'on obtient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
deux huile de pépin de raisin un peu de
beurre demi-sel
[Musique]
une fois qu'il est bien sur noisette
lorsque le beurre ne chante plus
on y met nos girolles nos cèpes
ensuite on va passer à la sauce on va
avoir besoin du pistou on a fait au
préalable
d'une casserole de la crème fermière
un petit jus de citron voilà tout
simplement on va prendre une seringue
et on va juste tirer un peu d'agastache
voilà
[Musique]
on va se mettre les champignons qu'on a
au préalable poêlé ensuite on va se
prendre l'oeuf qu'on a poché
et on va piquer
l'oeuf à la gastache et à l'eau minérale
ensuite
notre petite sauce
au pistou la gastache
[Musique]
finir le plat la petite émulsion une
petite entrée d'automne
[Musique]
donc notre petite recette d'oeuf poché à
la gastache cèpes et girolle
ma petite astuce pour pocher l'oeuf
fermier
c'est d'avoir un œuf très très très très
très
[Musique]
ça vous a donné faim Gabriel oui ça m'a
donné faim est-ce que vous allez tenter
de reproduire cette recette chez vous
pourrez honnête pas encore après j'avoue
que j'ai un peu peur de pas la réaliser
aussi bien kering boire moi en tout cas
bah si vous voulez tester de refaire
cette recette chez vous sachez que vous
pourrez retrouver le reportage sur notre
site internet avec la liste des
ingrédients et c'est bientôt la fin de
cette émission mais juste avant de se
quitter je dois un petit coup d'oeil à
la météo de demain
demain matin dans les Yvelines le ciel
devrait être très nuageux sur l'ensemble
du département au niveau des
températures il fera 6 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 5 degrés à Versailles
Rambouillet et Houdan dans l'après-midi
le ciel devrait rester couvert compter 7
degrés à aux dents Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles il fera environ un 6 degrés à
Rambouillet et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi jusqu'au
bout avec nous je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]